this video is sponsored by Skillshare
also spoilers obviously so Avengers
endgame it's out in theaters and what I
went to go see it opening day it made me
cry seven times and yes I count it but
that got me thinking how do films like
this create emotional scenes powerful
enough to make audiences like me cry
well today I want to talk about that
exactly using the seven scenes that made
me cry I'm going to explain what
techniques were used to create those
powerful emotional moments so that you
can use these techniques in your own
writing or maybe look out for them when
you're watching your own movies and
admittedly this is my own small way to
pay tribute to a franchise that I've
grown up alongside for the past eleven
years this is my video for Avengers
endgame I am Iron Man
[Music]
we do this all day
in Robert makes' screenwriting book
story he writes as audience we
experience an emotion when the telling
takes us through a transition in values
in other words in order for a scene to
be emotionally striking be it happy or
sad it is most effective when there is a
sudden shift from two opposing values
the greater the difference between them
the greater the emotional reaction from
the audience for example in Disney
Pixar's movie up the beginning of the
film has become widely considered the
most emotional part of the feature it
achieves this by showing us how Karl and
Elly meet fall in love and ultimately
grow old together
this in turn uplifts us as an audience
gradually and so once the writers have
brought us as high as they can do
naturally we then begin to experience
the transition of values it's revealed
that Elly someone who once was so full
of life and vigor is starting to slow
down until we finally see that shot of a
balloon floating towards her hospital
bed leaving Karl alone in a world
without the person he embraced the
adventure of life with this is tragedy
and that was one of the ways writers
like Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely achieved so much emotional
resonance in Avengers end game at the
end of 2018 Avengers infinity war finals
just manages to succeed in achieving his
goal in Avengers endgame the film picks
up right after those events as the
remaining Avengers ride together in an
attempt to correct an else's destruction
or as Steve Rogers puts it let's go get
this armed with Carol Danvers now by
their side the knowledge of worth panels
fled to and a plan to use the Infinity
stones to reverse the snap chair they
corner a weakened somewhat pathetic
looking Fanus on a farm he created for
himself the despair of the previous film
has now been replaced with an achievable
goal thus given the audience hope and
optimism for the future and bring back
all those that were lost until we use
the stones to destroy the stones
I am inevitable as an audience we like
the other Avengers think he must be like
until it's revealed by nebula that he
isn't slowly the reality sets in
without warning a distressed
guilt-ridden Thor slices off the head of
Thanos as the body of the mad Titan
collapses to the floor so two collapses
the hope and optimism we once had with
that the scene comes to a close
followed by the hardest gut punch I've
ever received from three words to appear
on a theater screen five years later
what follows is the desperate ruin the
world is lefted as the remaining
Avengers try to hold it together in
whatever little way they can the
audience is now at a low point and so as
writers do it's time to reintroduce hope
to uplift the audience once again about
halfway through the film there is a
scene that takes place in the 1970s with
Steve Rogers and Tony Stark these two
characters take part in two scenes
during this section those two scenes
being Steve's first time seeing Peggy
since her death and Tony's first
positive encounter with his father was
in this 1970s section of the film
Tony's uplifting scene and Steve's sad
ones served to enhance each other two
scenes expertly intertwined to achieve
the strongest emotional reaction for
both for example as Steve evades the
security looking firm he flees into a
random office within this room he finds
a picture frame of himself twenty-eight
years after his passing he notices that
the door reads Margaret Carter moments
later Peggy Carter enters the room
opposite Steve the woman he loved and
left behind in the 1940s he walks up to
the window and mourns the life that he
lost it's heartbreaking at the same time
while trying to succeed in finding the
space stone tony is confronted by his
father and through that interaction we
find that he is a reasonable man that
cares deeply about his family he was
cold he was calculating he never told me
he loved me and never even told me he
liked me despite the rocky relationship
Tony had with his father in this brief
but wonderful scene we see Tony fully
reconcile and appreciate his father for
who he is and what he did for
thus bringing us to her I consider to be
the most cathartic and thunderously
satisfying sequence ever put to film but
before I break down the best scene of
the film I want to quickly shout out
today's sponsor skills
storytelling is one of the most
difficult and nuanced skills out there
and one of the best ways to improve your
skills is by participating in a
community to discuss and learn skills
share is just that an online learning
community with over 25,000 classes in
design business and much more they even
have classes on writing as well as
character designs specifically it's
genuinely a terrific resource and if
that wasn't enough skills chair is also
giving away a two-month unlimited access
trial to the first 500 people that
clicked the link in the description and
after that it's only around $10 a month
so if you want to start taking your
writing seriously and want to learn more
check out Skillshare
[Music]
to fully understand how this scene
achieved what it did I want to first
take a look at this quote from Robert
McKee's book story consider these two
events lovers argue and break up
negative
next one kills the other the second turn
is so powerfully negative that the
argument begins to seem positive in the
light of the murder the audience will
look back at the break-up and think at
least they were talking then and it's
this very change in values from a
negative to an extreme negative in
tandem with the principles we explored
earlier in the video that made the
scenes so powerful it opens a stano's
announces to Tony Thor and Steve that he
will wipe out all of humanity and life
in the universe this time to prevent his
work from being undone this immediately
has held their minds as a stark contrast
to the original plan from the previous
film that led to only 50% being killed
off and so because the beginning of this
film took the time to show us the
real-life consequences of the previous
snap the stakes are now higher than ever
and the audience is now ready to
experience the largest value transition
of the film the fight begins and due to
a miscommunication between Thor and Iron
Man Tony gets knocked unconscious trying
to keep the pressure on Thanos cap
dashes in only to get smacked aside
immediately ducking beneath Thanos his
weapon Thor joins the fray once again
only to get quickly overpowered by the
mad Titan Thor is exhausted and cornered
pummeled by Thanos but there's hope Thor
reaches out for Stormbreaker this moment
is important to give the audience a
break from Thanos as relentless
dominance it also takes their focus away
from other characters as they are led to
believe Thor might have a chance if this
works
however anticipating this move fans
grabs the ax as it flies toward Thor in
an action that mirrors worth or did to
Thanos at the end of infinity war Thanos
begins to push Stormbreaker into the
chest of Thor
things are not good for the first time
since the fight began a hero's life is
at stake the audience is now ready for a
transition of values
[Music]
[Applause]
for the first time in a woman would
fight Captain America is taking it to
Thanos and because of the way this
reveal has been built up - in this fight
and previous films the results are
incredibly cathartic however this is
short-lived and Thanos regains the upper
hand and disarms Captain America of
Mjolnir
Thanos his assault is relentless and
savage viciously hacking and breaking
down Captain America's shield
symbolically this shield has always
represented the goods defense against
the forces of evil and right now it's
never been weaker a once flawlessly
strong shield is now a shattered shell
of its former glory
Captain America lays beaten and bruised
laying in a heap on the ground exhausted
as cap struggles to his feet Thanos
begins to explain that none of his
actions up until now have ever been
personal but that this planet he will
take great pleasure in slaughtering this
world and its inhabitants from existence
once this is revealed
Thanos unleashes his enormous army of
monsters in what looks like one last
inspirational act in defense of the
earth
Captain America tightens his shield and
stands alone against the forces of
Thanos and absolute defeat as an
audience we are currently at our lowest
point and it is now when we experience
the greatest change in values the entire
film has to offer suddenly a small light
appears behind Steve it quickly expands
bathing the entire screen in a warm
radiant glow
T'Challa flanked by Okoye and Shuri
march onto the field followed by Falcon
and dozens of other golden portals of
light punching and cutting through the
darkness all of the heroes that we have
come to know miss and love have returned
to fight alongside Steve in this final
great effort as the camera pans across
this incredible spectacle the music
swells when finally Steve says
[Music]
assemblé reunited and fighting alongside
one another for the first time in the
11-year history of these films ride
against a common despicable enemy we
experienced one of the most
awe-inspiring emotionally uplifting and
overwhelming sequences in the film
within the beautiful chaos that ensues a
number of character uniting czar given a
spotlight however none more so than
Peter Parker and Tony Stark working
effectively in the same way as Tony's
interaction with his father prior in the
film this is a moment in time that
clearly demonstrates Tony's emotional
development and maturity across the
franchise it's simple but incredibly
effective lovingly embracing his
surrogate son Tony has emotionally
matured the film is filled with
emotionally engaging scenes throughout
but none more so than these two
instances having been haunted by Thanos
as a looming threat and destruction for
11 years of his life Tony finally finds
himself in the unlikely position to
change it all but why was it moving the
screenplay of the film is structured
such that it continues to contrast
strong negative instances with positives
much like the other scenes in the film
we've discussed however changes in value
are not restricted to the films that
they take place in alone and this film's
greatest strength is it's paying off and
callbacks to longtime franchise spanning
story arcs and what do you say to your
other
The Merchant of death that's not bad I'm
just not the hero type clearly I am Iron
Man
you're not the guy to make the sacrifice
play to lay down on a wire let the other
guy crawl over you big man is sooo wrong
take that off what are you what made you
so special
nothing I'm just a different problem a
hero like you just don't know when to
give up
we do this all day you're a laboratory
experiment Rogers everything special
about you keep the conclusions to tony
stark's and Steve Rogers stories are
beautiful the giving up of a life and
the gaining of a new one
both poetic and beautiful in their own
different ways the film beginning in
Auto despair concludes with one
beautiful perfect moment in time the
marvel cinematic universe is filled with
funny memorable and heartbreaking
moments all expertly woven together into
a tapestry the likes of which we might
not ever see again endgame is a film
that rewards as viewers for the intimate
understanding of all the characters and
inhabitants of its universe resulting in
an experience that is both overwhelming
and spectacular full of payoff catharsis
and intense passion from start to finish
does anything that I have left to say
it's thank you thank you for these films
and thank you mom I love you 3,000
[Music]